Secret number two to writing viral
hooks, create intense contrast. You have
to say two things that absolutely don't
make sense next to each other. For
example, here's a headline I saw the
other day. How eeky guy ruined my life.
Eeky is a Japanese productivity hack
that is known to help millions of people
and somebody is saying it ruined its
life. Crazy contrast. Here's another
one. How to make more money by firing
your clients. Two ideas that don't make
sense next to each other. more money by
firing your clients. This creates
intrigue, curiosity, and people are
irresistible to clicking something that
has that much intense contrast. Try that
in your next headline. And if you missed
it, here it is